[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metry Sirin guten Abend die sportlichen
Highlights die gibt später wieder mit
dir Norbert ein schönen guten Abend noch
von mir wir blicken auf die Themen an
diesem Freitag
ein Land in Aufruhr nach massiven
Ausschreitungen bereitet sich Frankreich
auf eine weitere Nacht mit Krawallen vor
nach langem Hin und Her die Ampel einigt
sich beim heizungsgesetz die finale
Fassung geht nächste Woche in den
Bundestag
und Temperaturen bis zu 50 Grad im Süden
der USA und den Mexiko kämpfen die
Menschen mit unerträglicher Hitze
[Musik]
nach dem Tod eines 17-jährigen bei einer
Polizeikontrolle und drei krawallnächten
in Folge blicken sie in Frankreich
wieder hoch besorgte auf die kommende
Nacht in vielen Vorstädten brennt es
seit dem Vorfall hunderte Fahrzeuge
wurden in Flammen gesetzt hunderte
Personen festgenommen und es sind auch
ungelöste Probleme wie soziale
Benachteiligung und Rassismus die mit
voller Wucht jetzt wieder an die
Oberfläche drängen Frankreichs Regierung
ist alarmiert an der Arbeit
die Spuren der Verwüstung sind überall
zu sehen treffen auch kleine Städte wie
etwa rubé im Norden Frankreichs eine
Fabrik völlig ausgebrannt landesweit
werden mehr als 800 Randalierer
festgenommen in der dritten Nacht der
Gewalt die angestaute Wut scheint sich
ungebremst zu entladen
wir haben keine Arbeit nichts absolut
nichts und dazu kommt noch dass wir von
denen angegriffen werden die uns
eigentlich schützen sollen das ist
einfach zu viel daher kommt der Frust
wir sind wütend anders als von vielen
erwartet ruft Präsident macron nicht den
Notstand aus doch er kündigt zusätzliche
Mittel an bleibt dabei aber Waage auch
Sorge für neuer Gewalt werden feste
abgesagt der Nahverkehr gestoppt und
dann appelliert er an die Familie
der Festgenommenen letzte Nacht waren
Jugendliche teils noch sehr jung es ist
die Verantwortung der Eltern sie zu
Hause zu halten um die Lage zu beruhigen
müssen Mütter und Väter ihren Pflichten
nachkommen
nein nicht Beachtung droht die Regierung
nun gar mit Haftstrafen in den
Vorstädten wie hier hin und her dürften
diese Ankündigungen nicht gerade zur
dskalation beitragen meinen Experten
von einem Staatspräsidenten oder eine
Minister wird erwartet dass sie ihre
Verantwortung wahrnehmen sie sollten
Maßnahmen ergreifen die die Lage
zumindest beruhigen wenn nicht sogar
lösen können
doch danach sieht es momentan nicht aus
morgen findet die Beerdigung von naail
statt die im jugendlichen der von der
Polizei getötet wurde viel deutet darauf
hin dass Frankreich nicht so schnell zur
Ruhe kommt
Thomas Walde ist für uns in Paris Thomas
wie problematisch könnte es noch werden
wie schaut man auf die bevorstehende
Nacht
also die Regierung versucht ganz
offenbar zunächst einmal alles
auszuloten bevor sie einen Notstand
ausrufen müsste der etwa Ausgangssperren
mit sich brächte denn auch das müssten
die Sicherheitsbehörden erst einmal
durchsetzen und angesichts der Bilder
der vergangenen Nacht während dadurch
aus Zweifel angebracht ob das gelingen
würde vielen Jugendlichen geht es um
mehr als den Tod eines Jugendlichen es
geht um ihr Verhältnis zur Französischen
Republik den Institutionen und
Autoritäten statt aber die
dahinterliegenden sozialen Probleme
anzusprechen und anzugehen droht die
Regierung heute den Eltern und stellt
abends den Busverkehr ein ich denke das
geht ein bisschen am Kern des Problems
vorbei viel wird nun davon abhängen ob
die Gewalt weiter zunehmen wird in den
kommenden Nächten sollte das der Fall
sein würde recht schnell klar dass
solche hilflosen Ankündigungen der
Regierung nicht dauerhaft weiterhelfen
werden danke schön nach Paris Thomas
Walde
wochenlang gab es Streit in der
Bundesregierung über das heizungsgesetz
jetzt hat die Ampel einen überarbeiteten
Gesetzestext vorgelegt wir schauen mal
drauf künftig dürfen nur noch Heizungen
eingebaut werden die zu mindestens 65%
mit erneuerbaren Energien betrieben
werden können das gilt ab nächstem Jahr
für Neubauten für Bestandsgebäude sobald
eine kommunale wärmeplanung vorliegt der
Bund fördert den Heizungstausch mit bis
zu 70% schon nächste Woche soll der
Bundestag darüber abstimmen Karl
Hinterleitner
genau 110 Seiten sind es geworden der
überarbeitete Entwurf des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes vieles wurde konkreter
gefasst manches ist neu so sind die
Ausnahmen beim Heizungstausch für über
80-jährige gestrichen das wäre wohl
verfassungswidrig gewesen für Mieter
gibt es eine Kappungsgrenze maximal 50
Cent pro Quadratmeter darf der Vermieter
in den ersten sechs Jahren nach
Modernisierung erhöhen die Koalition
zeigt sich zufrieden aber auch
selbstkritisch dieses Gesetz wurde
wirklich vom Kopf auf die Füße gestellt
die haben da intensiv daran gearbeitet
innerhalb der Koalition und das was wir
jetzt geschafft haben bedeutet dass es
keine Verbote geben wird das ist keine
Eingriffe ins Eigentum geben wird und
vor allen Dingen maximale
technologieoffenheit das Klima wartet
nicht wir müssen tätig werden wir haben
es leider viel zu lange nicht getan und
ja man kann auch mit Selbstkritik und
das tue ich auch auf das Verfahren
zurückblicken denn da ist einiges nicht
so gelaufen wie es sollte und ich finde
das sollte uns anspornen das in der
Vergangenheit besser oder in der Zukunft
besser zu machen der Opposition reicht
diese Erkenntnis nicht der Zeitplan der
Regierung sei viel zu knapp und eine
Missachtung des Parlaments das wird bis
Montag niemand beurteilen können am
Montag ist die Anhörung ist haben
Sachverständige und Abgeordnete gerade
mal das Wochenende Zeit um 120 Seiten zu
lesen zu bewerten Schlüsse zu ziehen das
ist unmöglich Parlament heißt ja nun
auch die Opposition hat Rechte und muss
mitreden können und dieses Recht wird
durch so ein Verfahren schlichtweg
Adapter geführt die Koalition aber hält
an ihrem Fahrplan fest in der kommenden
Woche soll der Bundestag das Gebäude
Energiegesetz verabschieden
wenn sie sich weiter über das
heizungsgesetz informieren möchten
empfehlen wir unsere ZDF heute App dort
können sie unter anderem nachlesen wie
die Ampel damit für mehr Klimaschutz
sorgen will
das heizungsgesetz und die damit
verbundenen ampelstreitereien unter
anderem darin sehen viele in der
Opposition den Hauptgrund für den
Höhenflug der AFD und das bringt uns zum
aktuellen ZDF Politbarometer und zu
antippe hallo Antje hallo in der
aktuellen Sonntagsfrage liegt die AFD
noch mal zu ja die AFD kommt erneut auf
ein Höchstwert liegt erstmals im
Politbarometer vor der SPD wenn am
Sonntag wirklich Bundestagswahl wäre
käme die SPD nur noch auf 18 % - 1
cdu/csu 28% unverändert die Grünen
blieben bei 16 % und die FDP bei 6%. die
AFD liegt zum dritten Mal in Folge zu
und käme auf 19%, die linke 5%
dabei sieht eine Mehrheit die AFD weiter
äußerst kritisch und zwei Drittel meinen
dass die Partei eine Gefahr für die
Demokratie in Deutschland darstellt und
werden die AFD auf einem Höhenflug ist
ist die Zufriedenheit mit der
Regierungsarbeit gerade auf einem
Tiefpunkt aber davon kann die Union
nicht wirklich profitieren was bedeutet
das denn für das Führungspersonal ja bei
unseren Top Ten der wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker wird auch
der CDU-Vorsitzende Friedrich Merz
überwiegend negativ bewertet schreibt
man die Deutschen mit wem die
Unionsparteien bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl die besten Chancen hätte
nennen jeweils 22% Hendrik wüst und
Markus Söder CDU-Chef März kommt erst
ein dritter Stelle vor Daniel Günther
unter den unionsanhängern liegt Hendrik
wüst vor Markus Söder auf Platz 1 auch
hier kommt Friedrich Merz erst auf Platz
3 aber bis zur nächsten planmäßigen
Bundestagswahl sind es ja noch gut zwei
Jahre Dankeschön Antje nicht ganz so
lange dauert es bis zum heute journal
dort dann wie immer das komplette z DF
Politbarometer ab 2 und 20 Uhr
bei der Union da läuft es in den
Umfragen haben wir gerade gesehen
deutlich besser als für die
ampelparteien trotzdem rumort ist aber
cdu/csu vor Ort hätten sich heute auf
ihrer Präsidiumssitzung in München eine
große Dosis Geschlossenheit mit
entsprechenden Bildern und einem
Programm gegen die ampelpolitik aber
auch mit der Frage wer der eigentliche
Hauptgegner sei die AFD oder doch die
Grünen wie CDU-Chef März zuletzt meinte
aus München Alexander Pool
Hendrik wüst hat es eilig an diesem
Morgen bloß nicht noch so eine Frage wer
ist denn nun der eigentliche Gegner der
Union die Grünen oder die AFD wir sind
die Verbündeten mit der Menschen der
normalen Menschen der Wunsch nach
Normalität er steht heute über der
gemeinsamen präsidiumsitzung von CDU und
CSU in München gegen den offenen
Richtung Streit der letzten Tage setzt
die Union heute eine wohl formulierte
Beruhigungspille mit dem Namen Agenda
für Deutschland darin fordert sie unter
anderem Steuer und abgabenentlastungen
ein Nein zum heizungsgesetz und die
Senkung der Stromsteuer doch es ist die
Union selbst die immer wieder Zweifel an
der Geschlossenheit von CDU und CSU seht
die Frage wie man sich positioniert in
einem Jahr in dem mit Hessen und Bayern
gleich zwei große Bundesländer wählen
sind die Grünen der Gegner oder die AFD
Friedrich Merz meint die Grünen was die
Parteifreunde in Bedrängnis bringt die
in den Ländern mit den Grünen regieren
wie der hessische Ministerpräsident ich
muss das sagen das funktioniert sehr
konstruktiv das funktioniert sehr
zuverlässig und ich möchte sogar so weit
gehen zu sagen dass das harmonisch ist
was wir da machen eine Harmonie die den
Parteichef strategisch gerade gar nicht
passt in der Sache müssen wir uns heute
am meisten mit der Politik der Grünen
auseinandersetzen weil die Politik der
Grünen dazu beiträgt dass dieses Land
mitten in einer Deindustrialisierung
steckt sehr so Chef Söder dagegen bemüht
sich um eine Korrektur seines eigenen
Kurses reines ampelbashing vorerst Passi
wir müssen den Menschen schon auch
vermitteln können dass das jetzt nicht
alles nur Chaos nur schlimmes sondern
man kann auch was daraus machen in
München war man heute um Einigkeit
bemüht wie lange die tatsächlich hält
bleibt offen
morgen endet die Friedensmission der UN
für Mali ein wichtiges Datum für die
Bundeswehr und seit heute ist klar bis
Ende des Jahres müssen die Deutschen
ihre Truppen abgezogen haben das
entschied soeben der Welt Sicherheitsrat
die Friedensmission in dem
westafrikanischen Land die wurde 2013
beschlossen etwa 15.000 blauhelm
Soldaten hatten den Auftrag die Gewalt
islamistischer Milizen einzudämmen
darunter auch die Bundeswehr mit zuletzt
noch gut 1000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
ihre Vorbereitungen für den logistisch
schwierigen Abzug die laufen schon
Christiane hübscher
7000 Kilometer entfernt von Mali fällt
in New York die Entscheidung einstimmig
das UN-Mandat minusma endet mit dem
heutigen Tag ab morgen wird hier sechs
Monate lang nur noch eingepackt das sei
gut zu schaffen sagt die Bundeswehr auch
wenn es jetzt schneller gehen muss ein
Chaos wie beim Afghanistan Abzug sei
nicht zu erwarten wichtig ist aber
dennoch vergleichbar Afghanistan dass
man jetzt nach dem zweiten gescheiteten
Einsatz Stichwort internationales Krisen
und Konfliktmanagement jetzt in Mali
nach Afghanistan wieder evaluiert und
das Politik die Frage beantwortet warum
ist ein weiterer Einsatz gescheitert 10
Jahre alles umsonst laut Beobachtern
wurde der Einsatz in den eigentlichen
Krisenregionen fernab der Hauptstadt
durchaus noch positiv gesehen in Bamako
aber sammelt sich seit Monaten der
Protest der Bevölkerung gefüttert von
der Propaganda der militärhunderter das
magische Außenministerium die
Übergangsregierung begründen ihren
Abzug der benutzt man damit das in den
letzten zehn Jahren in dem die muss man
hier vor Ort aktiv tiefer in Mali nicht
genügend Erfolge zu verzeichnen waren
das heißt wir sehen ein sicherer
Situation die heute schlechter ist als
2013 und die malische Übergangsregierung
macht die minus mal dafür verantwortlich
Vakuum was nun in dem westafrikanischen
Land entsteht dürfte vor allem Russland
nutzen dem hauptverbündeten Marlies die
Gruppe Wagner operiert längst auch hier
das ist bitter das wird die Lage in Mali
weiter verschärfen aber natürlich kann
man auch nicht bleiben wenn man nicht
erwünscht ist Waffen Munition Fahrzeuge
Bundeswehr Gerät das in 1.400 Container
passt muss nun nach Deutschland
ausgeflogen oder vor Ort zerstört werden
möglichst kein Kriegsgerät soll in die
Hände radikal extremistischer Gruppen
fallen
ohne Konsens ohne gemeinsame Erklärung
zur Asylpolitik ist der EU-Gipfel in
Brüssel zu Ende gegangen Polen und
Ungarn haben sich bis zuletzt gegen den
Mehrheitsbeschluss gestellt den die EU
Innenminister erst vor drei Wochen
mühsam erreicht hatten der Kompromiss
soll die Mitgliedsländer verpflichten
geflüchtete aufzunehmen oder
anderenfalls einen Ausgleich zu zahlen
fangen wir nach bei ultra in Brüssel
offener Streit also was wird jetzt
eigentlich aus der EU Migrationspolitik
es gibt ja bereits eine Einigung der
Mehrheit der europäischen
Regierungschefs auf ein Asylkompromiss
was man auf diesem Gipfel erreichen
wollte war das Polen und Ungarn
mitmachen aber die haben definitiv und
ganz klar zum Ausdruck gebracht dass sie
bei diesem Asyl Kompromiss nicht dabei
sind sie haben sogar gesagt wenn er
kommen sollte werden Sie ihn nicht
umsetzen das hat hier viele sehr
geschockt weil damit mehr oder weniger
Polen und Ungarn demokratische
Grundregeln Europas verletzt aber das
ist auch wichtig Polen und Ungarn kann
ein Asyl Kompromiss nicht aufhalten
sondern man nimmt jetzt diesen Beschluss
den man hier im Rad gefasst hat und geht
damit zum EU-Parlament und hofft dann
ein endgültigen Kompromiss zu finden
vielleicht Ende des Jahres soll es dann
ein Gesetz geben und wenn dann wirklich
Ungarn und Polen ist wahr machen und
dieses Gesetz nicht umsetzen dann müssen
Polen und Ungarn mit schweren
finanziellen Strafen rechnen danke für
die Information
jetzt zum deutschen Arbeitsmarkt wo die
schwache Konjunktur Spuren hinterlässt
weniger Jobs sind im Angebot und die
Zahl der Arbeitslosen wächst im Juni
waren zwei Millionen 555
000 Menschen ohne Job 11.000 mehr als
immer also die Bundesagentur für Arbeit
im Vergleich zum Vorjahr ist das ein
Anstieg um 192
000 Arbeitslose die Quote liegt
unverändert bei 5,5%
und auch diese Meldung aus der
Wirtschaft lässt aufhorchen die
Darmstädter Software AG immerhin eines
der weltweit führenden Unternehmen für
softwareerlösungen und Dienstleistungen
gehört jetzt mehrheitlich einen
US-amerikanischen
it-investor Silverlake so der Name hat
sich die Mehrheit der Aktien an dem
knapp zweieinhalb Milliarden teuren
Unternehmen gesichert
in der Ukraine meldet die Armee weitere
Teilerfolge gleichzeitig wächst die
Sorge vor einer Atomkatastrophe in der
umkämpften Region saporizia halten
russische Truppen das größte
Kernkraftwerk Europas weiter besetzt der
ukrainische Geheimdienst warnt vor einem
Anschlag fehlendes Kühlwasser nach der
Zerstörung des kachowka Staudamms
verschärft die Sicherheitslage
zusätzlich über die Situation vor Ort
daran Hassan
das Atomkraftwerk in saporisha seit
Kriegsbeginn besetzt von russischen
Soldaten nach Angaben des ukrainischen
Geheimdienst soll Russland Angestellte
und auch Soldaten vom AKW auf die Krim
verlegt haben das bestärkt Befürchtungen
auf ukrainischer Seite schon letzte
Woche warnte der ukrainische
Geheimdienst das AKW Seifert es fehlen
nur noch der Befehl zur Sprengung
die Ukraine sagt wir würden uns selbst
in die Luft sprengen während wir auf den
Atomanlagen sind nun wie soll ich das
Kommentieren das ist eine glatte Lüge
den Worten des russischen Außenministers
glaubt niemand mehr in der Ukraine
Vorbereitungen in saporischer für einen
nuklearen Störfall es ist eine Großübung
von Polizei Feuerwehr und
Katastrophenschutz die gestern
zeitgleich auch in den Städten Knie
Bruch her sondern Nikolai stattfand
unsere Behörden und Einsatzkräfte sind
vorbereitet um alle erwarteten Gefahren
zu lokalisieren die von Russland ausgeht
auch für den Fall dass sie in
irgendeiner Form das AKW zerstören
würden es gibt verschiedene Szenarien
aber wir bereiten uns auch auf das
Schlimmste vor
die Menschen in saporisha durchlebten
diese Nacht nicht nur russische
Drohnenangriffe sie wissen auch um die
Situation um das nahe gelegene
Atomkraftwerk Russland führte bereits am
kachowka Staudamm eine Katastrophe
herbei in der Ukraine schließt man eine
weitere nicht mehr aus
unerträgliche Hitze das empfinden viele
bei uns ja so ab 30 Grad nach dieser
Temperatur würden sich die Menschen im
mittleren Süden der USA und auch in
Mexiko gerade zu sehnen bis zu 49 Grad
dort und das schon seit Wochen für ein
Drittel der US-amerikanischen
Bevölkerung gilt hitzealarm zu welchen
Problemen das führt und wie Sie damit
umgehen Christian Rechenberg
dass sie fürs Kuchen backen keinen Ofen
benötigen mag die Menschen im mittleren
Süden und entlang der Golfküste der USA
wenigsten die Hitze ist brutal die
Temperaturen über dem Durchschnitt seit
Tagen stellenweise ist es bis 45 Grad
heiß und bleibt auch so wenn die
hitzeglocke über dem Land wandert nur
langsam weiter
es wird schlimmer ja um ja wird es
schlimmer wir verbrennen hier
mindestens zwölf Menschen starben
bereits nicht nur wegen der Hitze die
hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit verhindert auch
dass die Körper durch Schwitzen Abkühlen
in Teilen dosiernas machen sich die
Menschen Sorgen um den Trinkwasser
Nachschub im ganzen Land ist das
Stromnetz an der Belastungsgrenze nicht
auszudenken wenn jetzt die Klimaanlagen
ausfallen
wir stellen Ressourcen zur Verfügung
damit die Menschen vor der Hitze
Zuflucht suchen können ehrlich gesagt
hatte ich gehofft dass es sich langsam
etwas abkühlen würde aber das ist nicht
der Fall
und die Behörden warnen kühlen Sie sich
ab gehen sie aus der Sonne passen Sie
auf sich auf und auf andere
man könnte sich fragen ist das normal
beginnt der Sommer normalerweise so und
die Antwort lautet eigentlich nicht in
Mexiko ist die Lage noch angespannter 49
Grad Celsius waren es Anfang der Woche
im Norden das Landes mehr als 100
Menschen starben bereits an Hitzschlag
Entspannung ist frühestens nach dem
Wochenende in Sicht bis dahin warnen
Wetterdienste weiter vor großer Hitze
die nun weiter wandert Richtung Florida
wir sind jetzt beim Sport heiße
Angelegenheit mal gucken wie das bei den
Handballern ist die deutschen u-national
U21 Fußballer sind bestimmt neidisch auf
die Handballer ja das glaube ich auch
denn das DFB-Team das war ja jüngst bei
der EM schon in der Vorrunde
ausgeschieden dass die hb-team dagegen
glänzt bei der U21 Handball Heim WM und
spielt nach dem 31 zu 26 die gestern
gegen Dänemark morgen im Halbfinale
gegen Serbien da ist schon von einer
goldenen Generation die Rede
ausgelassene Freude bei den Handball
Junioren in der Berliner Max
Schmeling-Halle gegen Dänemark lässt es
Deutschland erst gar nicht zu einer
Zitterpartie kommen geht direkt in
Führung und gibt diese bis zum Ende
nicht mehr her dies gelingt zum einen
durch einen konstant hohes Tempo in der
Offensive einer stabilen Abwehr und
einem erneut überragenden Torwart David
spät auch das dänische Supertalent
Thomas arnoldsen lässt die dhbauswahl
nie zu Entfaltung kommen bester
deutscher Werfer Nils Lichtlein der mit
viel Selbstvertrauen und frechen
Abschlüssen überzeugen kann alle
zusammen sorgen dafür dass der Traum vom
deutschen WM Titel lebt
der Spielplan für die neue Fußball
Bundesliga Saison steht fest
Eröffnungsspiel am 18 August Titel
Verteidiger München muss zu Werder
Bremen und 14 Meister Dortmund trifft am
ersten Spieltag daheim auf Köln
Enttäuschung bei den Deutschen
Springreitern gestern Abends in Aachen
beim CHIO Nationenpreis die
Titelverteidiger wurden nur fünfte zu
viele Fehler wie etwa auch hier
Hans-Dieter Dreher am Wassergraben im
zweiten Umlauf der Titel samt einer
Million Euro Preisgeld gegen an die
Schweiz erste Erfolg der Eidgenossen
seit 21 Jahren
[Applaus]
morgen startet der 110 Tour de France
los geht's diesmal im Baskenland und zu
den deutschen Radrennfahrern da ist zu
sagen erstens sind es weniger und
zweitens sind die Erfolgsaussichten eher
bescheiden
unübersehbar bassisch diese Tour aber
kaum Deutsch Simon gestisch einer von
nur sieben Startern meist in
helferrollen wie ihr Manuel Buchmann bei
Bora Hans Grohe dem einzigen deutschen
Team Etappen sie wie vor zwei Jahren
durch Nils das Maximum das erwartbaren
dass du Elvira gegen pogatscher steht
über allem der Dehner und der Slowene
werben um die Gunst der Basten
nach 31 Jahren wieder Tour Start im
Baskenland Radsportbegeisterung wie in
kaum einer anderen Region hier geht's
auch wirklich gleich richtig zur Sache
die Tour de France endet wie gewohnt am
Sonntag in drei Wochen am Pariser
Triumphbogen
diese baskenhelme sind hübsch aus helfen
vielleicht auch gegen Sonne so vielen
Dank Norbert die Wetteraussichten gibt
es gleich mit Christa Orden
Hessens CDU Ministerpräsident rein ab 22
Uhr im heute-journal Interview mit
Marietta Slomka ab Morgen begrüßt Sie
hier wieder Jana paralkes dankeschön
fürs Interesse schönen Start ins
Wochenende und auf bald
[Musik]
ja guten Abend die Natur freut sich
jetzt über jeden Regen und es gab hier
heute schon einiges an dieser ersten
Kaltfront unter anderem auch noch
kräftige Gewitter die wir aktuell vor
allem in Richtung Bayern haben und
morgen folgt dann schon wieder das
nächste Frontensystem das mit leichtem
Regen über Deutschland hinwegzieht
dahinter fließt auch etwas kühlere Luft
ein also in der Nacht ab Mitternacht in
etwa ziehen sich Schauer und Gewitter in
Richtung Alpen zurück dahinter wechseln
sich klarer Himmel und Wolken abstellen
weil sie gibt es Nebel in den
Frühstunden beginnt es dann von der
Nordsee her zu regnen und bei diesem
bewölkten Himmel bleiben die
Temperaturen hier bei 16 Grad bei klarem
Himmel sinken sie auf 9 Grad im
hessischen Bergland morgen finden wir
die höchsten Werte in der Altmark
Brandenburg und teilen Sachsens mit 25
26 Grad ansonsten bleibt es eher mäßig
warm mit 19 bis 24 Grad am kühlsten
dabei an der Nordsee denn hier aus dem
Nordwesten breiten sich dann die Wolken
mit dem leichten Regen im Tagesverlauf
auch etwas aus dazu gibt es einen
frischen südwestlichen Wind bis zum
Abend kommt dieser Regen voran bis zu
einer Linie Schwarzwald Brandenburg
davor bleibt es morgen freundlich ab
Sonntag gibt es dann noch hier und da
Regen oftmals ist es aber schon wieder
trocken und es geht vor allem im Norden
windig für alle aber eher mäßig warm
weiter mit 18 bis 26 Grad